what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we just got a brand new trailer for
secret Invasion and I have to say I do
love that we are getting another serious
Marvel project most of Marvel that we've
gotten recently has been pretty comedic
based which is fine but it is nice to
switch it up and get some serious action
and that is exactly what we are going to
be getting in the Spy Espionage Thriller
from Marvel Studios coming to Disney
plus focused around Nick Fury and the
skrulls now there are a lot of new
things to break down in this trailer and
if you recall from Captain Marvel then
of course from Spider-Man far from home
the scroll and Nick Fury are friends
such good friends that Nick Fury even
lets them impersonate him transform into
him and pretend to be him and help out
Spider-Man but this takes place after
that and as the trailer starts off by
saying Nick Fury has been gone for a
pretty long time in the post credit for
Spider-Man far from home we saw that he
was off world old it was in space on
some type of a spaceship base but now
he's back and we know why now this new
trailer starts off with a beam of light
coming down from space in the middle of
the woods and I gotta say I love this
because this is kind of what we humans
in real life have kind of thought about
aliens how they would come down a beam
of light from space picking up cows
picking up people aliens abducting
people this is kind of what we have
envisioned before for aliens and
essentially Fury is kind of like an
honorary alien here where he was with
the scroll the aliens in space and he is
now coming down from a spaceship to
Earth so I gotta say I love that but
then we hear him and see him speak with
Talus a leader or quite possibly the old
leader of the scroll and a close dear
friend to Nick Fury and Talos says Fury
since you've been gone things have
gotten much worse then we see footage of
a man holding up a Detonator clicking it
and blowing up some buildings in Russia
what looks to be Moscow and it could
quite possibly be some sort of an
embassy over in Moscow now notice as he
detonates the clicker he does appear to
be staring at somebody and although it
can kind of be hard to make out in the
next few scenes during the explosion we
can actually see who looks to be Maria
Hill in a group of people near the
explosion so it's possible that he is
looking at her and it is also possible
that Nick Fury could be there and he is
staring at Nick Fury but this character
right here is played by Kingsley Ben
adir and his character is graphic and he
is the new leader of the scroll
resistance which is primarily what this
series is going to be about the scroll
resistance invading secretly right
secret Invasion the world and that is
what Talos is referring to when he says
that things have gotten much worse and
Nick Fury replies to him by saying why
do you think I came back now more on the
character gravic in just a bit and more
on why Nick Fury wasn't there and has
been gone for so long as well now in the
next scene we meet a new new character a
character played by Olivia Coleman and
this character is Special Agent Sonya
falseworth and there are a couple of
really cool details that we know about
her so far one is that she is a
high-ranking agent in the British
intelligence service who has a past with
Nick Fury the Vanity Fair article that
recently came out about secret Invasion
said this about her sometimes she's
working with Nick Fury and sometimes
she's working against him as their goals
either align or Collide and based off of
the footage that we've seen so far for
secret Invasion we're kind of unsure
right now on whether she is working with
Nick Fury here or working against him
it's clear that scroll have invaded
Earth and they have invaded some pretty
big organizations another really cool
thing about her is that she actually has
a Captain America the First Avengers
Easter egg attached to who she is it
seems that she is a descendant of
howling Commando from Captain America
the First Avenger James Montgomery
falseworth now she calls him old friend
and we do see a scene where she is
walking with Nick Fury to his gravestone
so it's making it look like she is a
friend of his however if you pay
attention and listen very closely to
Nick Fury talk in this scene where he
says this is personal it kind of doesn't
really sound like Sam Jackson take a
listen and play it again if you need to
it kind of doesn't sound like him
this is personal
this is personal now maybe he is just
speaking a little bit differently in the
scene maybe he's a little choked up but
to me it doesn't sound quite like Sam
Jackson but let me know what you think
in the comments down below could this be
a scroll impersonating him and perhaps
Sonja is working with the scroll that's
impersonating him because she wants to
somehow infiltrate America or whatever
Fury could possibly be involved with at
the moment maybe even the Avengers Nick
Fury does State at one point in time
that he has to do this alone without the
help of the Avengers perhaps this is to
keep Sonia away also he's probably not
sure who he can even trust and I
wouldn't be surprised if we found out
during this series that some of the
Avengers at one point in time could have
been scroll because as we continue in
this trailer Sonia goes on to say very
few of us know about the war spot in the
shadows that have raged on this planet
of course she is speaking about the
scroll The Scroll of now infiltrated
many powerful organizations because of
course they can shapeshift and as we see
this we see Nick Theory back with Talos
we see Maria Hill and Everett Ross
seemingly doing some very big
investigative spy work and then we
finally see Amelia Clark and we know
about her character now her character is
actually the daughter of Talos Gaia is
her name and what's interesting is she
is kind of stuck in the middle of this
war she's upset with her father and with
Nick Fury and she's a little bit
rebellious at this point in time as was
explained by the article by Vanity Fair
however she might not be at this point
as rebellious as gravic is so she might
not be at the point where she wants to
betray her father and the other scroll
and join the resistance yet she's kind
of stuck in the middle and here's why
she's mad at Fury and here's why the
rest of the scroll are mad at Nick Fury
and are mad at Talus as the plot details
that we got from Vanity Fair explained
Nick Fury promised the scroll a lot
after the first Captain Marvel movie he
promised them a home he promised to find
them somewhere that they could live but
he hasn't delivered on anything in they
have been living in the shadows and they
have been struggling they even got to
the point to where they tried to go and
steal food but sometimes they get caught
and they have to be aggressive and
violent and they're just doing this so
they can survive but some of them have
had enough of it so now graphic is
leading those skrull who have had enough
of it and they are essentially taking
what is theirs after all they are aliens
and they can shape-shift and we can see
that there is a battle going on between
the scroll because we see this scene
with Talos confronting grab it grabbing
him and everybody else behind him all
the other scroll turn into ravic and the
reason they do this is to show Talos
look look at how many of us are actually
together right now graphic says guess
what the people behind me their scroll I
have essentially an army now and I'm
going to be fighting the humans and any
scroll who stand in my way now Emilia
Clark's character goes into some room
where it looks like there are thousands
of scroll that are dead and we even see
Sonya asking Nick Fury do you you feel
responsible so mini scroll could have
died and that could have been the final
Tipping Point that the resistance needed
to break away and start actually
infiltrating these powerful
organizations on Earth and that's why
Fury can't trust anyone even when we
hear the person say where are the
Avengers Nick Fury says this is a battle
that I have to fight alone because
scroll can shapeshift into Avengers 2
and we actually see gravic his
silhouette at least entering some sort
of very high security prison and this
could be him getting into some big
government prison because he could
shape-shift into an official and what
the scroll seemingly want is Nick Fury
they want to be themselves of course
they want to infiltrate and kind of
control the world essentially so they
don't have to hide anymore they consider
themselves an advanced species greater
than humans and if you actually take a
look at this scene right here at 127 in
the trailer we can see a suitcase and on
it guess what it says US Department of
damage control the good old dodc and on
the right side of that we see it says
specimen sample and here's kind of what
I think is happening here I think they
are actually creating a super scroll
towards the end of the trailer we can
see that gravic has powers his arm
extends kind of like Mr Fantastic but
kind of tentacally at the same time and
this could possibly be done by an
experiment and he could be the Marvel
MCU version of a super scroll and
another reason that we think that they
are definitely after Nick Fury is that
we see Nick Fury meet with James Rhodes
War Machine he at this point in time is
very high up in the military and they've
already explained that he's going to be
a prominent political figure in this
series and he tells Nick Fury you are
the most wanted man in the world right
now but here's the thing Nick Fury
hasn't really done anything which makes
us believe that scroll have been in fact
impersonating him and perhaps have been
causing destruction and terrorism as
Nick Fury in fact graphic in the
beginning when he detonated that
explosion perhaps he could shape-shift
into Nick Fury after and frame him for
that explosion in Moscow essentially
causing Moscow and Russia to believe
that America attacked them and we even
see milia Clarke's character Gaia tell
Nick Fury you don't know what they have
planned for you so the scroll resistance
is very very bitter and they want Nick
Fury to be held accountable for
essentially not taking care of them
they've had it they're done hiding they
are framing him and trying to start a
World War in which they would infiltrate
all of these very powerful organizations
in different countries and essentially
get all of the power in the world that
is what secret invasion is about so go
ahead and let us know what you thought
about this trailer in the comments down
below if you spotted any Easter eggs or
if you have any theories of your own be
sure to let us know in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest MCU news and theories you
can always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf wolf
foreign